الى الغرب من ايران تقف اسرائيل وهي تراقب
الوضع عن كثب القناه الثانيه عشره
الاسرائيليه افادت بان رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو عقد خمسه اجتماعات سريه
بخصوص ايران مؤخرا الاجتماعات جرت بعد
تقرير بلومبرج الذي تحدثنا عنه قبل قليل
وحضر الاجتماعات وزير الدفاع ورئيس اركان
الجيش الاسرائيلي ورئيسا المصاد ومجلس
الامن القومي اضافه الى غيرهم من كبار
المسؤولين الامنيين الاسرائيليين القناه
الاسرائيليه اضافت انه تقرر خلال
الاجتماعات رفع مستوى الاستعداد العسكري
الاسرائيلي لمهاجمه المنشات النوويه
الايرانيه بشكل موسع وبخلاف الاجتماعات
بعث نتنياهو رسائل لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي ومستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
والرئيس الفرنسي شدد فيها على انه اذا لم
يتخذ العالم اجراءات ضد ايران فستضطر
اسرائيل الى التحرك منفرده